hi I'm Nathan and curiosity is the worst
it's an endless dungeon crawl spawning
monsters of insatiable interest wrecking
weekends with intangibles like
creativity hands up if you finished this
game see a teenager wandering library
shelves I once thought that curiosity
was Whitman's noiseless patient spider
till the gossamer thread you fling and
somewhere oh my soul today I want to
kill that spider this winter I asked a
dozen friends about curiosity undress a
corporate researcher who maintains he
maintains the itch for knowledge by
bridging communities balancing breadth
and expertise like these famous
footballers philosophers Caspar an
activist theologian told me that
curiosity is being a humble listener he
takes special care to learn little facts
about many fields and cultures so that
he can affirm people who aren't
especially confident Casper often
reaches out to people for a personal
story acknowledging the whole person and
not just looking for the knowledge he
wants that they possess my friend Mark
who is a culinary polymath he's a
publisher and he's made visionary
technology for writers for 25 years
he drives full speed with curiosity he
writes the day is long and sleep is not
terribly important
don't let the guilt of chores deferred
quell your curiosity and be mindful of
times winged chariot to use time best
mark keeps immaculate lists Jamila who
I've watched cling to curiosity across
multiple jobs and night classes
disagrees with mark
she writes it's tricky to be curious
with purpose or results when you're
tired or feel filled up like your brains
a wet sponge perhaps we need the right
kind of time Anna who's a date of his
designer told me that curiosity needs
enough time to be bored
feeling that I had done
the sleeping and TV watching I needed to
recover from the working week she
actually structures her work and
schedule to fit in that boredom a
consistency that motivates her work but
if you're if your schedule doesn't
permit this kind of boredom perhaps you
can scale down your aspirations my
friend Dan keeps learning in the spaces
between his work with small projects and
Darius Kazemi is peace thoughts on small
projects is a great guide to this
approach but when we scale down we
sometimes miss our deepest passions or
our greatest impact meanly calls this
idle curiosity she says that a deeper
curiosity is driven by a broader purpose
and real-world challenges maybe it's
research for a meal exploring the
physics of surfing or the learning
involved in social action nini urged me
to connect new inputs back to my core
interests in a virtuous cycle that
continues to deepen engagement this
desire for impact can be in tension with
curiosity Christina and Tim described
the parallel need for talking and making
together curiosity and influence draw us
into themselves with more opportunities
or more questions around the corner and
people who spend all their time making
have fewer chances for impact while
people who spend all of their time on
visibility can lose their substance over
time may be the hardest challenge of
curiosity is self-awareness my friend
Ethan says that droughts of satisfaction
sometimes happen when we're most engaged
with the things we love when we're too
busy to celebrate those things and enjoy
the richness of what we've learned and
made together our loves become
obligations on the invincible Gantt
chart of despond my dad is one of the
most dedicated curious people I know of
a Timo immigrant who moved to the United
States for love without even knowing
English
he's a nightshift structural welder and
mechanic who's actually created the
foundations on many of the skyscrapers
and stadiums that you visit during the
daytime he wrote to me that the
consistently curious person knows that
discovery brings the most absolute joy
he's avoided promotion several times to
stick to his craft and stay curious
we've left behind the noiseless patient
spider but curiosity has no boss level
or speed runs to curiosity castle it's a
multiplayer co-op as my friends helped
me realize something a joy that thrives
in relationship so let's be curious
together at this conference
[Applause]